(interviewer) Imagine
ourselves 400 years ago.
They had about a 15% literacy rate.
And I suspect that if you were to talk
to someone who could read back then
and ask them, "What percentage of the
population do you think is capable of
reading?" They might have said, " Well,
maybe 20%, 25%."
Now you fast forward 400 years,
we know that's a wildly pessimistic
prediction or assumption. But
it's actually 99.99% of the population
is capable of reading. Well, what
similar blinders do we have on today?
So, I'm excited to have Carol Dweck
here, one of my personal heroes and
who strongly influenced a lot of the
work at Kahn Academy.
Carol, great to have you here.
(Carol) Pleasure to be here Sal.
(Sal) So, so, what I like
to start off with this word:
growth mindset.
Which I believe you
came up with.
(Carol) Mmhm.
(Sal) Um, when did you come up
with that? What was the
motivation and what is it?
(Carol) A growth mindset is when
students believe that their abilities
can be developed. A fixed mindset is
when they think, "I just have a certain
amount and that's it."
(Sal) This isn't just kind of
feel good talk,
this is actually based
in science, that you actually,
the brain actually does grow stronger,
neural connections actually do form
when you struggle.
(Carol) In study after
study we have shown that kids
who have a growth mindset get
higher grades. It's not a choice
between the outcome and the mindset.
It shows that, if kids engage deeply and
effectively in a learning process, their
grades and test scores are a natural
byproduct. Kids who are praised for
their intelligence, our research shows,
don't want a challenge afterwards, they
don't want to work hard on something, and
if they had difficulty, that's it. We find
that when we praise or parents praise
the process the child engages in, their
hard work, but not just hard work, their
strategies, their ideas, their focus,
their perseverance, then the student
learns these are the ingredients
of success. If it gets harder,
I'll just do these things.
We've already done work
with you, uh, inserting growth
mindset statements before a math
problems, and we found together
that kids did better.
(Sal) So one thing
that I hope is,
the folks listening to these
videos, go out there and tell
their parents, tell their children, tell
their peers, tell their teachers, tell
their students about growth mindset.
Tell them that their brain grows when
they get a question
wrong, when they
struggle, when they
look at their errors and
they say, "Hey, that's an
interesting!" That you shouldn't be
ashamed of your mistake, that
you should view that as something
that is interesting; something to
explore. When you do that, you will
actually, physically, form neural
connections. Your brain will
actually grow.